in the past three decades the Chinese
economy has undergone an extraordinary
transformation developing from an
inward-looking agrarian based society to
a major industrial powerhouse growth has
been rapid four years double digits were
the norm now the pace of expansion is
slowing down in the last quarter GDP
rose by 6.2 percent solid by many
standards but for China the worst
performance since the early 1990s the
government's been keen to offer
reassurance but doesn't deny there are
problems so Manya generally speaking
economic performance in the first half
of the year was within a reasonable
range and has sustained momentum and
overall stability however we should also
be aware that the economic conditions
are still severe both at home and abroad
global economic growth is slowing down
the external instability and uncertainty
are increasing the unbalanced and
inadequate development at home is still
acute the economy is under renewed
downward pressure much of that downward
pressure is a result of the country's
ongoing trade dispute with the United
States which has seen the introduction
of hundreds of billions of dollars in
punishing tariffs but there are
homegrown problems too for years Chinese
companies have taken advantage of
largely unregulated lending leading to
warnings of an impending debt crisis add
to that weakening global demand and you
have a cocktail for a further slowdown
in the future a source of concern far
beyond Beijing the sheer size of the
country's economy now means what happens
to China happens to the world for more
I'm joined by Kathleen Young from
fidelity international in Hong Kong and
our financial correspondent Daniel cope
in Frankfurt and I would like to start
with you Catherine because China's
economy grew 6.2 percent in the second
quarter that would be great for
economies such as Germany or Italy for
sure but for China and it's a
disappointment isn't it I wouldn't say
it's an actual disappointment and in
fact it was in line with consensus going
into the actual trade number itself I'm
sorry the economic data itself what we
do have to be mindful of is that we have
seen a deceleration growth for more than
a decade and this trend is likely to
continue so we really are expecting
growth between now and 2025 to really be
in the vicinity of between 5 to 6
percent which really fully reflects the
framework of the economy that we now do
see in China but nevertheless it is a
kind of slowdown and would you say that
it is mainly down to the trade war with
the US or are there other factors at
play there are a number of factors at
play so last year we did see sentiment
really weaken both because of the trade
related issues as well as because the
liquidity environment was just way too
tight so the cost of funding was too
expensive companies weren't reinvesting
the situation we find ourselves in right
now they're in for the rest of the year
is it corporates because of the ongoing
trade tensions have very little clarity
or visibility and therefore again
they're probably unlikely to react in
terms of reinvesting or the capex cycle
turning up because of these ongoing
negotiations between the US and China
all right this uncertainty is certainly
also something that is sort of hovering
over Europe Danyelle bringing you in how
is this Chinese data going down with
investors where you are in Frankfurt
well traders Monica at the Frankfurt
Stock Exchange we're not really
surprised about the growth figures we
have received this morning from China it
was expected here in by investors that
GDP growth would be between around six
and a half or six and a half percent
invested her seeing all of this not
really is worrying and I've been talking
to quite some of them this morning and
they're satisfied and that is more
the focus of investors this morning
about the growth in the industrial
production in China by 6.3% and also in
the retailing sector by 9.8 percent all
of this is making investors feel that
most likely the outlook for the second
half of 2019 is again more promising all
right one more question for you
Catherine because I found I heard that
PSA group the French carmaker group the
deliveries in China slumped 60% in the
first half of the year so that is quite
worrying you certainly for some foreign
investors is Beijing going to counter
any of that certainly the slowdown in
terms of what the government's been
doing they've been tweaking policy both
monetary wise and fiscally speaking but
in terms of what the focus should be for
investors for the third quarter fourth
quarter it really is on the fiscal side
of things so further infrastructure
investment not like we saw in 2008 but
more targeted infrastructure investment
and then really encouraging businesses
to again reinvest and doing so by
relaxing measures such as tax cuts etc
so really to aid sentiment versus
overall just boosting growth
all right carefully and young there in
Hong Kong and Daniel Cooper from the
Frankfurt Stock Exchange thank you to
both of you